the dilemma is always you know do you
make an ending that that's tidy and path
so that the risk of having it be not
realistic because tidy pad endings you
know they're satisfying but it's not
whatever it really happens right or do
you have it be a little a little looser
in the way that real life is at the risk
of of having it seemed too open-ended so
you know I've kind of done both in in
you know a few of my books I've gone to
some lengths to architect big
complicated endings that all kind of so
stick the landing and in other cases I
haven't haven't done so as much on the
internet there was a joke that if they
had given you the task of writing the
last episodes of Game of Thrones there
would be two more seasons where there'd
be bureaucratic minutia of having
rebuilding King's Landing
yeah I didn't get that job I do yeah I
do see the in in that another television
series I sometimes see things that my
initial reaction is that I'm looking at
lazy writing but I don't know if it's I
suspect what it really is is the
showrunner saying such and such thing
needs to happen right you know 35
minutes into this episode or else and so
then everything has to be rearranged to
make that occur and so so that's I think
when you sometimes see a character
suddenly do something that's out of
character you know which I think
accounts for a lot of dissatisfaction
that people felt when with the the last
part of that TV series kind of rushing
it
to a conclusion
you
[Music]